welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and with trailers like the one for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness teasing the mind-blowing return
of patrick stewart as charles xavier
some skeptics shrug off these promo
materials as marketing manipulations
trailer imagery doctor to lie and
mislead viewers into pain to see these
movies that don't actually include any
of these shots we all went ape [ __ ] over
and after seeing how trailer footage for
spider-man no way home scrubbed out two
spider-men and maybe still a little sore
over certain jungle runs in the infinity
war trailer dusted from that film when
patrick stewart even now claims that his
voice in that trailer might have been
imitated we should tell him the truth
it's difficult to know what the truth is
look folks obsessively analyzing movie
trailers has been my entire life for
several years now so when scott on
twitter asked me how often trailers lie
or deceive or beat and switch us with
shots they end up removing from the
final cut i realize it is a question
many of us have when we find ourselves
becoming cogs of the studio hype
machines wondering if screaming and
falling out of our chairs is really
warranted so in this video let us
explore the question do film trailers
lie explain
in my experience trailers can certainly
be deceptive and there tend to be four
major forms that deception comes in in
order of increasing level of
manipulation these are one deleted
scenes in which shots intended to be in
the final cut of the movie are included
in trailers but later removed during the
post-production process two spoiler
scrubbing in which visuals are
intentionally altered to digitally mask
details to better preserve the movie's
surprises three tonal misdirects in
which trailers intentionally splice
together out of context moments to
exaggerate the drama and four glamour
shots in which dramatic visuals never
intended to be in the movie are staged
for a trailer to make the film more
marketable now some people out there
claim that studios use glamour shots all
the time in trailers and while it has
happened it's actually pretty rare and
the reason i go so hard on these movie
trailers when they drop is in my
experience trailers don't really lie the
most common explanation behind shots and
trailers not showing up in the movie is
that they were simply deleted scenes
removed from the film later on in
post-production after early trailers
released with that footage still in it
let's start with many critics go to
example the trailer for avengers
infinity war it ended with the amazing
shot of cap and bucky roadie black widow
okoye black panther falcon and hulk
charging slow motion toward camera in
wakanda a shot that not only did not
appear in infinity war bruce banner
never hulked out fully at all in the
movie however when this trailer dropped
in november 2017 which was a full five
months before infinity war's release
hulk was planned to appear in wakanda in
this movie and this shot was going to be
in the film marvel confirmed this by
releasing behind-the-scenes footage in
animatics showing bruce and hulk during
their fight with call obsidian finally
working out their differences and hulk
bursting out of the hulkbuster armor
leading to him talking to natasha in
smart hulk form but late in the game the
film's producers decided this transition
would be too much of a victory for
banner and they wanted infinity war's
ending to be more of a downer so they
moved the smart hulk transition to
avengers in-game infinity war trailers
also included a shot of banner and
natasha that was removed a line from
thanos fun isn't something one considers
when balancing the universe
but this
does put a smile on my face also removed
from the final cut the spider-man no way
home trailer featured wong warning don't
cast that spell
it's too dangerous
and in the final cut he just tells
strange to leave him out of it they also
of course change strange saying scooby
doo this [ __ ] to a more family-friendly
trailer version please
scooby-doo this crap in-game trailers
also showed natasha on a gun range
removed from the final cut spider-man
far from home trailers showed peter
fighting gangsters in a restaurant that
was removed eternal's trailer showed
theena fighting in the hanging gardens
of babylon that was removed the iron man
2 trailer had an alternate take of
pepper throwing tony's helmet out of the
plane that was replaced when jon favreau
re-shot the whole opening to make tony
less of a drunk the star wars rogue one
trailer had a shot of jen urso facing
down a tie fighter atop that tower that
was removed when huge portions of that
movie were re-shot the amazing
spider-man 2 trailers showed footage of
harry osborn confronting peter about his
double life as spider-man early on in
the film but in the final cut harry did
not put this together until the final
battle thor ragnarok's trailer had a
shot of the four revengers on the
bifrost all lined up removed ragnarok's
first trailer showed thor's fight with
hella in the destruction of mjolnir in a
new york alleyway and that whole scene
was re-shot later on to take place on a
norway cliff in order to give odin's
death more dignity and weight and
looking back on all those films none of
those changes really led to me feeling
short-changed i honestly prefer
filmmakers feeling free to tinker with
and perfect their films right up until
the last minute and then you know later
release the deleted scenes on blu-rays
though uh don't tell that to the dude
suing universal for false advertising
we're showing anna to armist in trailers
for the movie yesterday before removing
her from the film not a joke folks now
the second category of trailer deception
and i find to be the most interesting is
what i call spoiler scrubbing this is
when vfx artists sneakily mask visuals
that might spoil parts of the movie most
recently this happened with spider-man
no way home's second trailer two shots
of spider-man in the final battle
removed the andrew garfield and toby
maguire's spider-man from this footage
now many fans did see an international
cut of the trailer that left in the
lizard recoiling from invisible andrew's
kick and i went even crazier to find
some motion blur left atop the statue of
liberty head also back in the infinity
war trailer the shot of cap struggling
with thanos showed the infinity gauntlet
with only the power stone and the space
stone but in the final cut of the film
thanos of course had also acquired the
reality stone the soul stone and the
time stone as well at that point so the
trailer made it seem like the avengers
were gonna have a better shot against
thanos in this movie and thanos might
not have gotten all six stones until the
later film thor ragnarok trailers used
footage of chris hemsworth in that final
battle before they added the detail of
his eye having been swiped out by hella
avengers endgames trailer showed captain
america during the time heist wearing
his darker infinity war era suit not his
classic 2012 era suit that he wears in
the film all to hide time travel being
the part of this movie in-game trailers
also showed the avengers group shot in
the compound but they digitally removed
fat thor and left out smart hulk so that
those would be saved as fun reveals when
we saw the movie in spider-man far from
home a promo clip included nick fury
saying about mysterio vic is from earth
just not owls but in the final cut the
line was altered too mr bett is from
earth
just not yours yes ours versus yours in
the promo to hide the reveal that this
nick fury is actually an
extraterrestrial scroll i love when
movie trailers do this because it makes
trailers their own narrative experiences
and creative puzzles designed to excite
viewers without spoiling the whole movie
and it engages the insane die-hards on a
kind of clue hunt that gets us even more
hyped for the film but this video is
brought to you by the ridge the ridge
wallet is light sleek and industrial
it's designed to fit in your front
pocket unlike those bulky monstrosities
that make a sit crooked when they're in
our back pockets the ridge comes in over
30 styles and colors including carbon
fiber and burnt titanium it holds up to
12 cards and still has room for cash so
you can show up your fancy euro
collection to cashiers and other people
who probably don't care every ridge
wallet comes with a lifetime guarantee
and they'll let you test drive it for 45
days and send it back for a full refund
if you don't love it they also have
great backpacks phone cases and other
cool gear so get 10 off today with free
worldwide shipping and returns by going
to ridge.com new rockstars that's
ridge.com new rockstars and use code new
rockstars find the link in the video's
description now the third category is
tonal misdirects in which moments from
the film are recontextualized to
artificially create drama or intrigue
contrary to what is actually in the
final cut now of course all trailers are
montages of highlights stitched together
out of context nothing wrong with that
but this is when trailers force in false
needle drops designed to break the
internet for example the trailer for
captain america's civil war showed rudy
falling and hitting the ground hard
i was wrong about you
now civil war was a huge event in the
marvel comics in which major characters
died captain america goliath and yet no
marquee characters died in the civil war
film now we knew after we saw this
trailer that roadie probably wasn't
gonna die why would they show that in
the trailer right but we figured at
least someone would and yet this movie
was definitely less deadly than the
trailer suggested it would be also the
trailer for star wars the rise of
skywalker included this moment yes it's
in
uh yeah the voice of palpatine a puff of
vader's breath and then a shot of hooded
ray with a double bladed red lightsaber
of course in the final cut of the film
revealed to be an illusion but in a
trailer certainly misleading really
trailers showing dream sequences or
hallucinations is often what leads to
audiences feeling misled the most like
infamously trailers for kangaroo jack
made it look like this is going to be a
movie about a talking kangaroo
[Music]
kangaroo jack when really this moment
was just one brief scene where jerry
o'connell's character briefly
hallucinates the kangaroo talking and
rapping and that does not happen
throughout the rest of the movie
sometimes the misdirects are actually
part of the story like in iron man 3
trailers and other marketing focused
heavily on the mandarin as the villain
you don't know who i am
you'll never see me coming
and yes even though ben kingsley's
character is revealed in a twist to
actually be a patsy this movie's first
half does at least try to maintain that
charade until that midpoint reveal so
you can't really blame the trailer for
that really the most egregious and
rarest type of movie trailer deception
is what i call glamour shots because
these days increasingly a lot of trailer
imagery is really coming from
pre-production camera tests like matt
reeves the director of the batman
actually intercut shots of robert
pattinson's wardrobe video for that
first trailer at dc fandom in august
2020 and joker director todd phillips
released a trailer that was really just
a camera test with walking phoenix i
don't think there's anything wrong with
these they're clearly presentational not
pretending to be moments in the film
they still did a really good job evoking
the tone of those films but the
deception occurs when studios insert
shots and trailers pretending to be
moments from the film but were never
actually planned to be in the movie
trailers for the force awakens focused a
lot on luke skywalker force is strong in
my family my father has it
i have it
my sister has it
you have that power too so not only was
this shot of distraught luke skywalker
grabbing r2 not in the force awakens
sure an alternate angle was in the last
jedi luke had zero dialogue in the force
awakens and this line was never spoken
anywhere in the sequel films similarly
the trailer for spider-man homecoming
ended with a team-up shot of spider-man
and iron man gliding through a city
street side by side awesome
but a shot nowhere in the movie and
since these two characters only team up
suited on the staten island ferry this
shot was likely never intended to be in
the final cut sony's marketing for
spider-man homecoming was in general
criticized for focusing way too much on
iron man this is a smoking gun but still
despite all this i think you can look at
these examples that i've mentioned in
this video and conclude while deception
has certainly occurred none of these
cases really amount to a studio outright
lying about what would be in a movie
like luke skywalker did appear in the
movie and factored heavily in the sequel
spider-man did team up with iron man in
that movie it's not like iron man didn't
exist in the movie at all civil war was
darker than your average mcu movie and
marvel did intend hulk to hatch out in
wakanda and when the trailer for
infinity war dropped in november 2017
marvel still planned on that being the
game plan it's just that movie's
cataclysmic ending and the challenges
they've always had with trying to vfx
hulk into these movies they could not
make it work for the end of infinity war
so now when marvel takes the step to
include patrick stewart's voice in the
trailer for multiverse of madness it's a
different situation folks the question
is not could someone have faked the
voice or did marvel just put it in there
to screw with us wrong sir wrong the
question we should ask is who and what
else is marvel still hiding from us
beyond the periphery of this trailer and
of course to that question the only real
response is why do you ask questions to
which you already know the answers yes
you're continuing search for hope yes
hope follow me on instagram and twitter
at e a boss follow me rockstar subscribe
to nerox stars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you